so let's talk about this album when does
the album actually come out because on
march 25th okay so we got a few weeks
but um so we'll hold on to this until
closer to the album but uh
you got some dope features on this
project but the t-pain feature
just was
super unexpected because i'm listening
to the album and the version of the
early that i have doesn't have the
features on it so i'm just pressing play
and i'm like yo this [ __ ] is hard and
then
[ __ ] see paint yeah yeah t-pain was that
an easy act like pain is the coolest
mother i'm real tight with pain i've
been like pain is my guy so
people like he's the most humble if he
[ __ ] with you he [ __ ] he's the
chillest dude i've met for sure so far
it's out of him and thundercat and fly
low yeah yeah i'm saying so what was the
t paying like like like when you cut
that record did you specifically say
like
i need to pay no this will happen when i
cut the record i went to the cave to
work with kenny beatz okay you know what
kenny b
so
i work with kenny beats at his own
studio you guys have a joint project
yeah yeah unlocked yeah like when we
together the duo is unlocked okay
he's incredible i've been trying to get
him on the show he like went on his
twitch and like
played a part of my interview talking
about how dopey is it was like we made
it and i was like damn and i'm like all
right we'll come on the show then
man you might be connected yeah
i'll talk to kenny man no he's a legend
but continue but yeah so i was at kenny
b studio this was like early 2020
this is where i just went there and we
wanted to work on some tracks like you
know
and um he was playing beats and
everything then
he he played um
he was like he played something he
played on the sample of troubles okay
and then i just started writing to it as
he was making the beat
and i only wrote the hook so i was like
got some trouble with that these drugs
can't fix we might struggle because
life's a [ __ ] they get happy when your
ass get rich blowing money cause our bag
ain't [ __ ] so he heard it and he was
like yo just go in the studio bro just
go in so i'm like all right i go in the
studio i lay it down i lay down the
verse i laid out two verses and
basically you know he was just like this
is dope i sent it to my management it
was like oh this [ __ ] five that's not in
the third like we like this this is
gonna be the hit i know this is gonna be
the hit
and then i'm just like yeah whatever
[ __ ] so
i remember um i was reaching out to
people at this point because like i
wasn't working as much with f and z
anymore
and i was just reaching out to people
seeing who was gonna hit me back and i
was reaching out specifically to
producers
not even to artists and t-pain was just
one of those artists i wanted to reach
out to because i just wanted his insight
with you know yeah with just
music
and
me and t-pain's relationship it started
at bonnaroo festival in 2018 like he
liked my cipher of course i grew up on
his music i grew up on rapper turned
sanga of course and then you know him
and adam developed from workaholics was
cracking jokes backstage back and forth
i love that show it was like it was like
death comedy jam or some [ __ ] have you
ever seen him to interact it was funny
as [ __ ] that sounds amazing um
i do my set he do his set we still
cracking jokes with each other we
exchanged numbers this time at third
that's how our relationship started
and then you know i reached out to him i
was like hey i'm about to call you
because you know i changed my number i
don't know if you changed his number
um
reached out to him and i was talking to
him just picking them up and just
letting them know like yo you're a
legend i know you don't get appreciated
as much because like all the things that
happened in the industry but bruh i'm
letting you know that i appreciate you
and what you've done for me just growing
up you know what i'm saying like all the
[ __ ] you did with dj khaled of course
you did with rick ross all the [ __ ] you
did with plies all the [ __ ] you did with
lil wayne and even all the [ __ ] you've
done yourself even freak neat like if
you guys t pain one two punch yeah on
those khalid records yeah even the stuff
you did with kanye west yeah come on man
you know what i mean
so he would really appreciate that and i
wanted his feedback on two tracks that i
have on the album
so
one of them was worse coming to worst
and i sent troubles they were two
opposites and those were like the
leading singles for me before i made any
of the other records
sent it to him and he gets back to me he
said he loved troubles and he was like
words come to worst is fire too if i was
you i'll put both of them [ __ ] out at
the same time on different blog sites
and i was like
that [ __ ] ain't gonna work you know what
i'm saying well also
blog sites like whatever year is it yeah
i mean so
he really loved the troubles record he
really liked that record so my manager
mark a year later he was like hey we
think about sending that record to t
payne to see what he's going to do with
it so i'm like all right whatever you
know you send it to most people most
people don't get back to me because it's
me right you know what i'm saying even
though they don't know me like that you
know
so
basically what happened with that was t
i'm going in the muay thai class and
t-pain texts me he's like
yo
and i'm like yo
he didn't reply and i'm just like i
whatever so you know i'll call him
probably at some point then the next day
um i'm at my homie powers career which
who also um produced on this record
and you know we going over some stuff i
get a text from t-pain a dropbox folder
and i opened a folder and you know i'm
listening to it and i was like oh this
is troubles and this time the third you
know and then next thing you know his
voice comes up i'm like oh [ __ ] i start
spazzing because the man ripped it and
he gave me classic t-pain like
that everybody knows facts you know what
i'm saying he gave me t-pain t-pain he
gave me him great record and what he was
writing about was so real and i know you
felt it you know
i felt that [ __ ] firsthand and i was
even i even got self-conscious a bit and
i was just like damn should i change my
voice he was like nah and then power's
like nah hell nah bro like that's the
record like you got to keep it like that
so i'm like you know what you're right
and i was feeling self-conscious because
i'm like damn t-pain ripped it but i'm
like that's the pain
you know what i'm saying no i mean
that's
he's one of them ones i mean like i
think of him and akon and like little
wayne in the run that they had when like
around the same era
and like how they were just on
everything
it was like each of them had like three
years and they just kept passing the
baton it was like a con then it was pain
and it was weighing in pain and then it
was just when it was it's every remix
everything it was crazy